vous enviez une bd allons au québec
véritable carte postale sur le vietnam
14 jours 12 nuits et surtout un film sur
l'adoption et sur le désir d'une mère
québécoise de rencontrer la mère
biologique de son enfant
je vois que c'est l'histoire d'une
réconciliation entre l'occident et le
rien anne dorval incarne cette mère
adoptive tiraillé entre la tristesse la
peur et l'amour pour une rare fois au
cinéma
la scénariste marie vien voulait montrer
l'adoption du point de vue des mères
l'idée ce fonds vient de mes deux
enfants j'ai deux faits allaient katumba
pluviers vient de lâcher la plus jeune
vient du vieux le tournage de 14 jours
12 nuits s'est étalée sur six semaines
il ne s'est pas fait sans difficulté
pour le réalisateur jean-philippe duval
on est dans un pays communiste parce que
ne rentres pas maintenant qu'il veut
avec des caméras
le scénario a été caviardé page après
page je tiens à dire que nous avons
tourné quand même l'intégralité du
scénario
les enfants sont l'avant guillaume les
ports anne dorval qui en était à son
premier voyage en asie
le choc est important je suis débarqué
de l'avion j'avais très peu virus avant
de partir alors quand je sortis de
l'avion je me ramasse à l'hôpital d'un
oeil pendant deux jours ça aussi chuck
c'est un apprentissage
ce voyage a aussi été initiatique pour
la comédienne française léa nature qui
joue le rôle de la mère vietnamienne est
ce que c'est vrai que j'ai
et j'ai très peu l'occasion de parler à
coeur ouvert avec mes parents on est
quand même issu d'une culture où il ya
beaucoup de non dits je pense elle que
pourquoi y ait 14 jours 12 nuits est un
film parfois contemplatif qui mérite
d'être vu
ne serait-ce que pour cette grande
synthe sur le bord de l'eau où anne
dorval est au sommet de son art je
serais content que parler de cette scène
c'est certainement ma scène préférée
étonnamment j'ai fait 14 morts la main
pour aller fini ce film là et pour aller
filmer cette scène là il nous n'avons
fait qu'une seule prise et c'est la
prise que vous avez vu et quand ça a été
fini les acteurs photo et bélanger et
moi on pleure un show de la 14 jours 12
lui prendra l'affiché le 6 mars ici oui
philippe ouimet radio-canada mort et a
dormi